foreign
Campbell video on a separate topic also
I believe in this last week
in which he and again he is among the
most careful analysts of the covet
pandemic that I'm aware of
um but this one is quite shocking and
also matches a different prediction uh
in a way it's not quite as clear-cut but
I think you'll um I think you'll see it
hey Zach can you yep you're right uh
yeah
out of their guidelines here now this is
managing breathlessness so this was
published remember on the 3rd of April
2020.
and they say this consider an opioid and
a benzodiazepine
now um what they mean there is an
opium-based drug like morphine and the
bendo benzodiazepine they talk about is
midazolam
now this is a classical well tried
trusted form of treatment that we use
for things like terminal agitation part
of terminal care when people are dying
of conditions such as cancer and things
that are incurable to manage a peaceful
death and it's completely the right
thing to do in the vast majority of
circumstances but what seemed to happen
was nice just took that and transposed
that into the covered situation and
covert of course we know is an infection
and most people can get completely
better from it what Joanna Campbell says
here is that and this is a British
um memo that he is unearthing here a
British Memo from uh April of 2020 in
which a recommendation was made for the
treatment of patients who have very
serious effects from
uh covet these are hospitalized people
who are clearly in Jeopardy of death
the memo suggests the application of a
two drug protocol one an opioid
um like morphine and the other
benzodiazepine uh like midazolam
and his point is this is shocking to
hear because that combination is well
understood and properly used in medicine
in patients who have a terminal disease
at the very end of their pathology
that this is effectively palliative care
that uh
allows life to be ended by prioritizing
comfort in a patient for which there is
actually no medical help
and what John Campbell says here is this
doesn't make sense in the context of a
coveted patient no matter how close to
death they appear because what they are
sick with is an infectious agent that
they might fend off right the fact is we
have which people do yeah we have all
had the experience
of being very very very sick and then
suddenly being on the mend and headed in
the right direction and what has
happened is your immune system has
figured out the formula sufficiently
well that you go from a trajectory that
if you followed it far enough would take
you to death right and suddenly your
trajectory is in the upward direction
and you may not feel great but you feel
a hell of a lot better because you're on
the mend the the infection is being
reduced and his point is look that
happens in people so it does not ever
make sense uh to
give a patient a
deadly if compassionate pair of drugs in
the case that what they're sick with is
an infectious agent that they actually
might beat
and I will say the title of uh his video
involves the term euthanasia which
I struggled with a little bit because
this is an official memo suggesting a
use of this drug cocktail this isn't the
case in which somebody has said well
this patient you know
uh should be
humanely put out of their misery this is
just medical recommendations that result
in the same thing now I don't know
whether that's an accident or not but I
will say there's a segment those who
watched my last Joe Rogan uh discussion
1919. there's a section in there in
which I become uncomfortable and I
actually discuss my discomfort I say you
will hear me hesitating to say this but
I can't help but wonder I say something
like I keep revisiting the part of the
pandemic in which we are applying
ventilators to desperately ill people
ventilators that we later came to
understand were doing more harm than
good they were actually killing people
and my thought the thing that I was
struggling to express to Joe was
that one of the effects of using
ventilators as the standard of care for
patients who they actually harmed was
that it drove up the number of people
who plausibly died of covet and so from
the point of view of justifying a
Draconian response to covid it made
covid look that much worse than it
actually was and again I'm not saying
covet isn't a terrible disease I think
it's much more dangerous than the case
fatality rate suggests but nonetheless
driving the number of
dead from covid people up did cause all
of the panic that then ensued that
caused us to lock down and do ourselves
damage that way to mass children all of
the things that we did
we're Downstream of the implication of
the desperate seriousness of this
disease and we were introduced to think
this by many things including fraudulent
video out of China that misrepresented
uh you know people dying on the street
this sort of thing so anyway this is not
as secure as a autopsy result that
matches a mechanistic model
um of the pathology that arises from
mRNA vaccination but it is another place
where a prediction
um is now manifest in other words I
didn't see this drug combination thing
coming but it is perfectly consistent
right the idea that uh a standard of
care that increases the number of people
who die of covid was not just one thing
it wasn't just ventilators it was also
uh apparently the at least in Britain
the prescription of this combination of
drugs and who knows how many other
things
which is also consistent with a total
failure to advise people about the
hazard of vitamin D deficiency a total
failure to apply the drugs that we had
that actually uh were highly effective
against many uh mRNA viruses like uh
like Ivermectin so anyway it is again
part of this pattern that is very hard
to
um
very hard to miss once you see it we do
all sorts of things that appear to have
increased harm rather than decreased
harm and you could imagine medicine is a
difficult business sometimes you're
going to do something thinking it will
be helpful and it turns out to be the
opposite but when you start doing that
across the board you do everything
that's unhelpful it raises a question
about why that happened yeah no and it
goes It goes on and on and on as you say
you know locking people in their homes
um away from the Sun away from the
ability to do physical activity
um I recently ran into again a picture I
think maybe out of Italy somewhere of uh
the police scooping up sunbathers
because because those were the people
who were at risk and putting other
people at risk right being alone outside
catching the Rays and generating vitamin
D
and
um
you know we had as as obesity became
clearly a comorbidity for this disease
and a really strong one and we talked
about some of the really remarkable
evidence for that we had a Resurgence of
the idea of fat shaming as the problem
right it's it's like and again you know
maybe we'll get there later in this
episode but like it's the it's the
people who are shaming others
um that is the epidemic here
it's it's not the fact that actually
there are going to be regardless of
whether you like it or not or think it's
fair or not
mechanisms by which this virus is acting
in your body that allows it to do more
damage if you have a lot of fat on you
it's not that shaming
it's not yeah I remember uh
the sheer number of places where
even just a basic understanding of covet
and how it transmits would have not only
given you a different prescription but
the inverse was stunning and I remember
you and I looking at each other I I
think I remember a image that we showed
probably have a newspaper article
discussing how they were closing down
the trails and the state parks and the
beaches right and we're just thinking
you're actually going to harm people
because if they're not outside
they're going home to an environment
where somebody may have covid and
they're going to catch it whereas if
they had been outside at that time they
would have virtually no risk playground
strung with caution tape
for months and months and months
children weren't allowed to play on
playgrounds I believe they literally put
sand in skate parks yes
I mean yeah that's just ludicrous I mean
that's that's like almost uh
for a little while their skateboarding
was a crime wow yeah how did we not see
that yeah um but you're right they made
skateboarding a crime
um and just the sort of
um
anti-fun you know and kids weren't
threatened by Cove in the first place
right and you're pouring sand in their
damn skate park right you're screwing up
their world they can't go anywhere
they're not going to school you're going
to take their skate park from them with
sand like yeah you're just a terrible
person that's right
foreign
[Music]